cet écran vient s'enrouler et se
dérouler des deux côtés c'est le slide
des bulles solo de Samsung display alors
puisque Samsung peut venir plier des
écrans il peut venir également les
enrouler alors l'intérêt de l'enroulable
par rapport au pliable c'est que vous ne
sentez pas la pliure parce qu'il n'y en
a pas ça s'enroule fatalement et le truc
qui est aussi très cool c'est qu'il
vient sans rouler alors là on nous le
montre il s'enroule d'un côté l'autre il
permet d'abord un très grandes tablette
mais l'autre sujet qui est aussi
relativement intéressant c'est que dès
lors qu'il vient son rouler et bien les
pixels viennent s'éteindre forcément
s'adapter d'un point de vue logiciel
parce qu'on va pas venir faire consommer
de l'énergie avec un truc enroulé sur
lui-même ça n'aurait strictement aucun
intérêt mais une fois de plus c'est la
modularité qui est là alors moi je suis
déjà très partisan et j'aime beaucoup
les smartphones qui splient mais c'est
vrai que le roulable ça quand même un
intérêt supplémentaire je sais pas si
vous ça pourrait vous plaire la grosse
problématique on pourrait en tout cas
imaginer retrouver aujourd'hui et bien
c'est toutes les certifications
résistance à l'eau et à la poussière
est-ce que en s'enroulant ça risquerait
pas de venir enrouler des impuretés à
terme d'abîmer l'écran j'ose imaginez
que ça me saoule travail avait déjà
travaillé et avec notamment de nombreux
brevets pour éviter ça à voir si ça
arriverait vous seriez plus team
enroulable ou plus team pliable marquez
moi ça dans les commentaires